there is one extra diagram it's a simple
one is what s your diagram we need to
actually work out this volume and the
important thing is it's these triangles
clearly right once I work out the area
each of these triangles i'm going to
multiply by a width have a look what
kind of width is it going to be it's a
delta x because look it's horizontally
oriented right so once i work out the
area i multiplied by Delta X that's my
thickness and then I add them all up I'm
going to internet you can see it's
actually a very very simple domain to go
on up so let's draw this diagram each of
my triangles is going to look quite
different but I'm just going to draw a
typical one something that might be in
the middle I'm going to draw this line
down the middle because it'll be
important to me in a second I want to
work out the area of this triangle okay
now you tell me what do we know about
this triangle already okay so it's it's
isosceles and remember we said it's not
just a sauce with a side length one cool
that's helpful what else do we know
about this okay now the base length of
learning that the base length comes from
these vertical lines and this is why
this diagram is kind of helpful to us
right so each one of these vertical
lines the green ones represents this
whole length okay so how do I work out
what this whole Lake is yeah because
half of it is why I get this is from the
as to why yep then y coordinate so since
you have two parts of it you end up
having to why funny entire base perfect
okay so you can see just in case you're
not catching downright that distance
that I put there is a distance like this
that's that distance right half of the
base okay and clearly that's the y
coordinate which is just to find out
contacts so therefore I've got this part
is y which is contacts so the base is
just double that however I'm not even
going to work out what double that is
because when I work out the area of a
triangle I'm gonna have to hard that
anyway so i'm going to call this i'm
gonna be a bit naughty and put another
thinking this is half the base pass the
base so to get the area of this triangle
all I need now is the height yeah the
puppet of your home so that's this
length here age how do I work it out
just Pythagoras yeah in fact this is a
special triangle right this is this is
the Pythagorean triangle in the unit
circle this is side squared plus cos
squared equals 1 square right so in fact
this is just say X okay if you like of
course you can actually say let's just
do the whole thing H equals the square
root of 1 squared minus cos squared X
you're like oh yes that's going to be in
this case all I'm interested in is just
the positive value because it's a height
yes so I'm just go save being in two
lengths I don't worry about the negative
case I mean the fact that i put a
scrubber you like the front means that's
the only I really should put that here
I'm not interested in the negative
solution okay
right so now just as a bit of working to
help me and you'll see there's really
really been working required i'm going
to say the value is equal to all right
what am i adding up and what's getting
smaller we already had the width of all
of these triangular slices right so what
an epic show right at the front what'd
you do cut me up thank you weird remark
ok now I'm adding stuff up okay what am
i adding and we're okay now importantly
i am going from not to plan to but the
reason i meant a lot to plan to and not
for instance need one to one because
sometimes you have to do it that way is
because look where I'm adding from i'm
going horizontally i'm marching across
from here to here yes so that's why i'm
going to say x equals 0 and i'm not
supposed to okay all right now what are
these things that i'm adding up well I'm
need the area and i'm going to multiply
by delta x which is the width of all the
triangles so we already established the
area is based on tight on to which is
based from sight on to so what's it
equal to what is missing yeah very good
I'm gonna write the sign at the front
because it's going to be useful for me
in a second and then I've got my width
of all of my triangular slices okay this
is not complicated at all let's do this
turn it into an integral right so I'm
going from not supply on to while you're
at it while you're at it you might say
oh hey sine x cos x but it's not two
ways to do this clearly you could do it
by armed you could do this by reverse
chain rule to do you notice that because
if you cheat this is your f that's f
dash right but you know I I don't
immediately go there my brain goes first
here yeah yeah
and that's an integral yes okay so i can
integrate this fairly easily I'm going
to slap that puff out the front and then
I'm going to say ok when you integrate
this where did it come from just the
side to X it came from negative a half
close to that's right because you've got
there there are two things happening the
negative comes from the fact that causes
turns into negative signs you correct
with a negative and where does the half
come from it comes from the inside
derivative Frank so i'm going to
multiply by this by negative a half and
then that leaves you with a cos 2x in
side yeah can we just don't check
because we did a couple of things in our
hair if you differentiate cos 2x you're
going to get negative 2 sine 2x by that
negative 2 is exactly to the kids so
here so you're fine ok that leaves you
with a negative 1 over 4 out the front
ok what's going to be inside you
negative ok i'm actually going to do the
right the the values first so COS of pi
minus cos of 0 minus a quarter close up
I of course is negative one minus one so
that's negative to you its volume
okay now I'm really glad we got a look
at that in like mmm really like
sometimes you want numbers to come out
nice and when numbers come out
disastrous so you're like oh no i've
done something wrong but then you look
at this you that well maybe they're too
simple okay so here's what I'm going to
do remember before I asked you before I
asked you what do you want to compare
this into what do you want to compare it
to does anyone have any ideas okay so
you could take all right I've got some
small triangles over this end I have
some other small triangles on this end
right so therefore soar in the middle
this kind of like an average triangle
and then i can multiply across however
that's going to be problematic for me
right because well number one there's
the base which caused a problem number
two this in fact is not i mean i called
it an average triangle but it's
averaging the sense of width versus
height but it is not average at all if
comparison to area right because in fact
you have zero area on this in zero area
on that end so this guy's not average
he's the biggest one of the world right
or somewhere in there okay so therefore
a prism will get me somewhere there but
it would be problematic here's what I'm
going to suggest this shape on the
bottom it's really good it's curved okay
but the shape that is closest to in
terms of polygons is a triangle isn't it
like here here here here I know I'm not
big mouth large part of it but at least
I've got the basic idea right in the
same way when I look at this whole shape
member said opera house sale type theme
it start slow and it comes up to this
I'm top here right now if I'm willing to
convert this sorry not convert
approximate this with a triangle right
see is blue outline here i can put
approximate that with a triangle too now
if i do dad what kind of shape
do I have you're going to get something
kind of like a pyramid right in fact
you're going to get a triangular pretty
we get rid this number so you can see
properly which has four sides and
because it has exactly four sides we
call it our design will do we call it up
we call it a tetrahedron so here's what
I want you to do I want you to picture
that that is my simplified base down
it's my simplified [ __ ] okay and one
letter come up from there is they're
going to come up to a point like so okay
so use my tiffany john and all i'm doing
here is trying to work out well if I can
work out the volume is see it should be
roughly the same ballpark as as bad yes
okay well I need some dimensions right
for a pyramid does anyone would expect
you to remember because back in stage 5
then I remember the volume of a pyramid
formulas length I'll give you a clue it
starts with things yeah very good see if
you get back base area right and then
you take the perpendicular okay so let's
have a look let's do them once at the
time on that area how would you like me
to work out almost very close what's
this base if I call about the base
that's going to be one that way one that
way this is to do you agree if I'm
defining that is the base where is the
perpendicular height very good in some
it's Tracy along the x-axis isn't it
right that's PI on too yeah yeah you're
close right so it's a diff for the area
of the base is a half base times height
so it's one of plan to define one of the
height of this pyramid
I actually got a perpendicular here
right and this has to be this what this
thin one by 11 isosceles triangle right
so that gives me a plan okay a third
time's you taught me the base area I
love to you said behind one so this
apparently is PI on 6 which I think
you'll find is about 0.5 to which is not
too shabby at all okay now of course
that was just an approximation exercise
right but at least we know in the
ballpark i think it's somewhat
coincidental they ended up so close
because you see we added some areas we
took away some areas but